Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom are making
it official that's right the couple took
to Instagram in the early morning hours
on Friday posting this same selfie which
look closely features a gorge flowering
that you look happier than ever and just
check out all those heart balloons how
about some romance right
Orlando captioned the pic quote
lifetimes while Katy went with the pun
writing full bloom these two are so cute
and while the couple didn't exactly
confirm that she's wearing an engagement
ring they were quickly congratulated in
the comment sections by fans who believe
the ring meant they were headed towards
wedding bliss yes and then Katie's mom
spilled the beans on Facebook posting
several shots of the sweet couple and
the ring writing look who got engaged on
Valentine's Day that post has since been
deleted even though everyone side all
side mom we also saw this Katy's
adorable pic of her man sleeping in bed
with his two pups writing will you be my
teenage dream cuties the two have been
living together recently and in January
Katy shared a sweet post for Orlando's
birthday writing happiest 42nd birthday
to the kindest and cutest man I've had
the pleasure of spending time with of
course this will be the second marriage
for both Katy and Orlando he was married
to Miranda Kerr from 2010 to 2013 and
the two have an eight-year-old son Flynn
now Katy was married to Russell Brand
from 2010 to 2012
okay so let's break down how bloom came
together I just love that come along
with such a cute little coming I don't
know whoever came up with that props
Katy and Orlando first met at the Golden
Globes after-party in January 2016 and
then they dated until February 2017
before they called it quits then they
rekindled their romance in January 2018
and here we are exactly and at the time
a source told et that one of the main
reasons for their split was quote the
pressures of constantly being in the
public eye and not taking the time alone
to just be together which would explain
why the on-again couples seemed to make
it a priority to take getaways together
our source adds that time together
created quote a stronger sense of trust
and a
for each other something Katy and
Orlando were not shy about when they
talked to et about their romance she's
amazing she's you know I'm super proud
of the work that she does she's she's
she's a voice that speaks to so many I
think every relationship is everyone's a
teacher and a relationship that's how I
see it now and we've taught each other
in Laughlin now despite their brief
break up it seems Katy has learned more
about wellness from her fit fiance last
year she told ET how he challenges our
to up her game
hey I see Orlando on Instagram the man
works out he looks good I mean he's
always trying to get me a hike yoga eat
vegan oh my god it is like I'll hike to
Taco Bell with you
I sure will Crunchwrap supreme extra my
extra onions I mean I'm kind of wit Katy
there I love a good Taco Bell milk
crunchy tacos you know they've got that
balance she brings the Taco Bell he
brings the fitness anyway Thursday was
clearly a big day for the pop star not
only did she say yes but she also
dropped a music video for 365 her new
song with Zedd
[Music]
well it looks like Orlando is officially
her 365 guy and of course we'll have all
the latest on Orlando and Katy so make
sure to subscribe to all things UT I met
Hallie underscore Steven and I met
Courtney underscore teza know
bye for now guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]